[Music]
all right another day another massive
border failure from joe biden because
according to border official sources
speaking of fox news.com border patrol
is not using title 42 rapidly to expel
migrants despite it still being in
effect but are still processing some
under title eight now this comes as
democrats are in yet in another election
day conversion oh you look at swing
states border states you know states
like oh beta o'rourke running in texas
all of a sudden people like beto
o'rourke and
let's see
mark kelly in arizona
the democrat from nevada they're all of
a sudden calling on biden to delay the
removal of title 42 as the border crisis
is worsening by the day because
americans they're keeping a keen eye on
the open borders the record of march in
terms of illegal immigrants coming into
the country and of course under the
sanctuary states of america under joey
biden now four in 10 americans are still
highly concerned about illegal
immigration things are only going to get
worse we see migrant caravans once again
beginning to line up and according to
new findings from gallup and sarah
carter's on the ground in texas with one
texas rancher that says biden's border
crisis is getting worse by the day all
of this is unfolding before our eyes
take a look
how much worse is it now than it was
before under the biden administration
right now you were just talking about
that
i've been here four years
and the biden administration when it
started january it started you could
nearly
put it on the book january last year
it was like a floodgate
three years prior to that i probably
fixed
maybe five six
ten at the most holes in three years
right now from the day that the biden
administration took over i have fixed
172 holes in my fence is that a warning
too to the administration they're
refusing to do anything here
well if you could talk administration
needs to get off their butts and get
down here and take a look the ones that
want to vote for this better life come
down here and see what and spend a month
with us
i challenge them come down here and see
what we're going through if they do
repeal title 42 if they take it away
it's gonna get bad
it's gonna get real bad
it will get bad and way worse than
people think investigative reporter
sarah carter joins us now uh she's in
mcallen texas tonight all right so
we know it's getting worse but it's kind
of interesting to watch the politics of
this but they might delay uh the repeal
of title 42 what to help beto o'rourke
out to help uh nevada senator out uh
mark kelly out in arizona is that the
only reason for the delay and then as
soon as the election's over they'll go
and repeal it after the election because
that's the way i see it
well sean that's uh that's what they're
feeling from their constituents so you
have senator mark kelly kirsten cinema
and others chris kuhn senator chris
coons you have a democrat here in texas
henry cuellar the congressman who for a
long time and i'm going to give him that
has been fighting both the obama
administration and then and now of
obviously the biden administration to
stop the floodgates from opening right
now under title 42 they were able to
expel and that's according to border
patrol numbers about 110
000 people back to mexico so they
returned them back to mexico they're
expecting once title once title 42 drops
may 23rd if it's rescinded by the biden
administration we're looking at 18
000 people a day that is according to
numbers now coming from dhs i'm right
here on the border sean right across the
rio grande river from me if you can see
behind me it's very dark right now
is mexico i can tell you right before i
got on with you i was watching people in
the brush hiding in the brush looking
around we had border patrol helicopters
up above we have border patrol
patrolling the river right now as well
as national guard right behind me
imagine the way it is now it's a 79
percent increase since last fiscal year
so this year alone in the first six
months since october there's been over 1
million people that have come into the
country in march alone 80 000 people
were released into the nation that's a
79 increase and what law enforcement
officials are saying and what exactly
what the rancher was saying and everyone
else is saying is look this is a
self-inflicted wound of the biden
administration and it's only going to
get worse if they rescind title 42.
it's unbelievable and march was the
worst of all what 220 000 encounters
with the illegal immigrants those are
the ones we know about correct that was
a record
and those were just in march in march
that was 220 000 encounters in march 80
000 released into the country those are
the numbers that they're giving us right
now and by the way the ones that aren't
released into the country they just go
through a different route and they end
up getting their way in usually anyway
uh sarah great report hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else